il a rebranché françoise hardy il a
métamorphosé france gall et il a revampé
tuner à l'idée sans pour autant ne plus
préoccupés puis même voici michel berger
michel bienvenu son plateau de troupes à
la une alors comme telle attaque de
philo et puis on le look assez
romantique a déjà été bien enseigné dans
nos rôles de se jeter préparé un
questionnaire de proust rajeuni tu très
très mauvais pour ça je te croyais il
faut de jean bricmont des choses très
drôle depuis qu'on l'attende des choses
très profondes
ah bon il faut lui leur première
question quel est pour toi le comble de
la misère à voilà je verrai contre 13 au
premier degré je sais c'est qu'ils t'en
fous tu meurs de faire ce qu'on a vu les
images de d'enfants en train de moulins
de saint pie depuis quelques mois à la
télé ça c'est vraiment chaud de
rattraper une mouche
quel est ton idéal de bonheur terrestre
alors là si je dirais blonde 1 m 65
l'issue du marathon metteur en scène de
cinéma favoris de diana kubrick je le
ferai bien petite comédie musicale donc
pas un grand favori à bas coût de saison
on sait on pourrait être favori j'ai pas
prévu à des snow se sont passées de ce
qui est terrible genre de choses c'est
qu'on est apparue celle c'est terrible
est-ce que tu serais capable de tuer
quelqu'un ça coûterait très cher
non mais c'est quoi les seuils pour moi
je serai capable
oui tu me regardes tu aurais tu aimé
être si tu étais plus michel berger
j'aurais bien il imite karl les mistral
doit cesser dit qu'ils étaient attendus
monde de 200 m 200 m mcenroe 50 sportifs
que des tests et tu par dessus tout
répond très vite aller question est de
savoir en effet chez toi tu as la survie
de l'âme typique l'on déguste coupage
pour les vins se situe enfin dossier
d'écran et les missions et les
trafiquants des cités les ados et voilà
c'est une très bonne question pour
l'heure fait signer comment tu aimerais
tu mourir
ok no mercy sur la sellette dans l'une
est la charité à l'interview vérité
michel verger bonsoir avant de parler
pour nous au 33 tours on va parler de
starmania en urss pour commencer on ça
s'est passé comment le les premiers
jours j'ai vu les premiers spectacles et
rêver les gens qui ont besoin de
spectacle incroyablement et qui sont
scellées slider inner wheel un livret
c'est vrai il ya l'iran russes ont
installé un autre un petit programme ont
leur expliquer le sujet moi j'ai parlé
avec des jeunes
après alain poncet et
l'infection 13 as extraordinaire sur
pouvoir général janvier ça n'a pas dû
beaucoup les étonner les russes quand
non mais c'est peut-être un qui m'a dit
que c'était ça dure a pris son chef de
bureau
moi j'ai fait grimper c'était le point
de pouvoir de l'un par rapport à l'autre
c'est quelque chose qui est très
important pour en ce moment et c'est
vrai qu'ils ont applaudi seulement la
faim qui sont pas aussi réagir quand le
spectacle alors ici peut-être est sacré
de la chanson un avs ai peur qu ont
inspecté ce qu'on lui dit qu'est ce que
ça leur plaît pas du tout et ça a
explosé à la fin c'était s'est fait fort
alors maintenant starmania et vendu à
tim rice des créateurs de jésus christ
superstar et d'évita on va le voir à
londres son service estime wright
d'affaires les têtes c'est parce qu'il
est plein pour lequel j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles j'ai envie de faire des feux
d'artifice cause ces deux choses qui
leur fait donc ça a présenté les choses
pour nous manquer a dit qu'il allait
faire ce genre a presque fallu aux
comédies musicales qui est en train
d'écrire là la légende de jimmy
avec l'abandon et c'est l'arrivée des
transferts pas mal
oui il ya diane tell tale choisi c'est
sur c'est quoi l'histoire c'est pas un
peu rétro déjà visuellement ça passait
pas grand deane arrêtant huit ou dix
minutes
de la série policière de l'adolescence
du ralliement dans les années 90 c'est
un jeune type qui comprend pas pourquoi
elle et pas de gêne pas c'est un truc
assez particulier décalé cc oui je crois
que c'est un script s à l'adolescence en
fait on valoir cran ça commence le 22
septembre à mogador ses filles
c'est justement ça devrait l'être le
moment illégaux achoppé quand même en
arrive à le faire bosser dessus mal non
arnaud maintenant je crois qu'il ici que
s'il faut aller là si tu voyais la
liaison kanako de chebbi pour le
surveiller sa grande fille membre à bon
alors le nouveau 33 ça ne tient pas
debout
ouais 50 est parfaite dit pourquoi pas
ce que je voulais
patrick ollier non mais s'il faut que ce
soit un besoin et qui était vraiment
devenir maison qui dit dadis ferait rien
tant que ça sera pas quelque chose donc
je serais pas capable de faire quelque
chose d'entièrement différent si
auparavant bon jusqu'ici
ouais quoi s entièrement dégagé la route
elle discute jamais pareil j'aime bien
mais aussi entièrement nettoyé
[Musique]
oh
je pense pour les gens de toute manière
tout ce que je ferai tout prix ce sera
pareil selon certaines sources avancent
et le même sens si j'en suis là mais
pour moi pour moi c'est une évolution
énorme
ah ouais parce que j'ai d'abord les
cliniciens et qu'elle travaille et je
reste sans doute jamais trahi avait il
ya une autre époque c'est l'émission de
new york très qu'il ya une violence
énorme en deçà et il ya une espèce
d'énergie très très dur que je voulais
avoir un projet des textes et puis en
même temps deux été très émotif tu sais
je crois que c'est peut-être que pour
moi que c'est vraiment tout à fait
différent et c'est ça qui compte
rochette qui font souvent à toute autre
confession il est également la chanson
titre c'est une chanson sur les
handicapés on comprend pas exactement
quand on écoute le discours quand on
voit les t-bonds on ne peut pas se
tromper
oui c'est pas un peu beaucoup de séries
l'émission de bernard tapie serait dans
les capellans en lui même qui vous je
sais pas j'ai l'impression qu'on passe
un peu d'un extrême à l'autre qu'ils
voient c'est à dire que les handicapés
se répand dans des allées personnes
seraient occupés aujourd'hui on fait des
heures 30 on fait des matches dans
l'autre sens où c'est pas une chanson
solide handicapés mentaux lui fait en
tout cas ses 10 ans sur le handicap
l'appareil voilà une carte sa place de
leader ça pue yeux quelqu'un qui est
vu qu'un problème par l'hébergeur a key
largo newey
c'est une fille sur ses vraies questions
qu'il souhaite faire passer c'est c'est
le regard des autres sur lui ça c'est
quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup frappé et
ça me frappe prauthoy ça m'est arrivé
trop de fois soit neuf ans trop de gens
j'ai avec sa soeur pu voir tu dis
souvent dans tes chansons pendant ce
disque là d'ailleurs en particulier pour
moi qui ai plus de tolérance
est-ce que c'est pas un jeu vraiment
est-ce que c'est pas angélistes de dire
aujourd'hui quel est son nom mais il
était passé par un chanteur engagé mais
dont un peu dans le sens du poil chez
moi tu prend pas beaucoup de risques
parce que dire au jour d'aujourd'hui
qu'on veut plus de tolérance est ce que
finalement c'est pas enfoncer une porte
ouverte que de dire que l'on la mise en
cohérence et pas du tout banalité au
contraire parce qu'on obtient des
résultats concrets avec ce discours un
peu néo humaniste un peu de charme en
disant d'un sens mais est-ce que les os
qu à plus de tolérance sks que les gens
du tiers-mondisme moment les prendre les
artistes alors la jeunesse d'aujourd'hui
voilà moi de mettre en action réglo un
chanteur entière quels sont les
résultats
ça vient vite à ces changements d'abord
de mentalité les adultes mais david est
le point clé par exemple si on si on
parle d'eux
guild of attendu toute chaude jambes je
crois que la grande réussite ça c'est
qu'on a réussi
les artistes de la route musique dans
mon entier ont réussi à donner l'image
de ce que pourrait être le monde comme
ils ont créé un modèle qui veut dire oui
ils ont montré si on avait envie de
faire quelque chose si on avait envie
dire ça c'était assez insupportable de
vie dans une commune était qu'on peut
changer les choses
c'était possible sachant que ça on est
l'article
il ya autre chose qui me choque chez toi
c'est que daniel balavoine
c'était sûrement un bon copain à toi un
ami dont tu accepté la critique
c'était bien quelqu'un qu'avait bon
coeur qu'ils aient des bonnes chansons
mais est ce qu'on peut en faire
aujourd'hui un maître à penser est ce
que c'est pas grave de faire de
balavoine nyck de vries à mettre à fond
ce n'est pas pareil coin la contestation
de balavoine quand vient le nom disions
tout ça pas eu de quelqu'un si tu veux
comme si c'était un grand non seulement
philosophe avec vous parce que c'est pas
exagérer pas ça du tout - j'ai bien ses
chansons elle pourrait me philippe rivet
et j'ai envie de continuer avec ses
chansons c'est tout y sera pas plus loin
que ça non pas toi faut pas mélanger tu
vois il se retient trouve vraiment que
beaucoup de gens font ces mélanges et
quelqu'un qui écrit des chansons avec un
maître à penser de dire si il écrit les
chansons qui nous plaisent
ça veut dire qu'il va avoir des
solutions sûres et ça je comprends
vraiment pas mélanger espoir jusqu'au
fond cas pas un désir sincère de faire
du bien
comme ton père qui a inventé la grève
durera qu'un mec bon et fait du bien à
l'humanité c'est évident est-ce que tu
senti très bien
3 quand on est médecin fait du bien
parce qu'on peut trouver des trucs que
tu as pas finalement et désirs refoulés
de faire du bien mais je crois que ma
fille puisse faire ni bien au match
contre x alors là c'est vraiment séjour
à saint jouin ils s'étaient affrontés
arrive à leurs soucis dans les liens
textes vous faire du bien est ce que
t'as pas été déçus par la politique
finalement parce que c'est quand même
bon t'as sutil mitterrand 88 qui allait
souvent à l'elysée il ya toujours pas de
chaises musicales mon cher michel berger
un cap a été un peu trahi non mais moins
les limites de la politique je trouve
que rien n'existe profondément équipe a
quand il parle du seuil de tolérance par
exemple oui oui il était d'assurer la
maintenance
non mais moi je suis capable d'être
d'accord avec quelqu'un sur tout
simplement on l'a quand on a un choix à
faire on peut soit mon arbitraire et la
met
c'est vrai que la chaîne musicale a
toujours pas d'ailleurs pas encore
rendue en partie l'elysée il est visé
comme les gens dit moi je trouve ça
assez bon président et si je compare ce
qu'il veut avec
avec les autres finalement c'est un
message
moi je peux me tromper j'ai l'impression
que c'est quelqu'un qui est assez
sensible à les choses justement une
année et on veut dire est ce que tu
crois
il ya une expression de woody allen plus
conforme d'un j'espère qu'il a une bonne
raison il se trouve c'est vrai j'ai
spatiale une raison si l'église parce
qu'il ya des choses qui sont vraiment
qu'ils paraissent pas logique
en faire une interview première fois
enfin d'accord
mon premier souvenir qui était dans la
chambre s'était montée sur une chaise
que j'écoutais la musique il se faisait
il était chef d'orchestre un bâtiment et
ouais mon frère a trouvé ça complètement
stupide c'est justement là pour ça mais
raté concertiste est et yanis 9 juillet
à quatre mains tous les deux n'ont gère
un professeur allais près sur les arabes
et dwyane wade le pôle solfège sinon
c'était ma grand-mère smacl piano et
puis la mer étudie tout le monde croit
que je sors du conservatoire en fait ces
parages et vous foutez musicale d'abord
un gros chien bon pianiste est
totalement trouvé un bon très très
mauvais tienne il a appris à vivre il
fait défaut alors oui mais aussi le
premier disque que tu as acheté sa série
charmed le premier leader et sharp
équipe et une pochette blanche et
petites lunettes noires du feu à la
maison quand même temps c'est en tout
cas à l'intérieur la s'intéressent
vraiment quelque chose
la première ci avait quitté fait labour
était blonde
parce que moi je suis très heureux de
savoir partie sur les noms on épouse et
lui s'étaient passées c'est comme lire
de la musique sans connaître la
partition pour la première fois et au
fus
c'est l'aptitude you c'est très très
personnelles mais parce que j'ai la
moins 15 ans j'ai commencé à gagner ma
vie en écrivant des chansons ce qui
était quand même très particulier et
j'étais très très vite lassé indépendant
j'ai le même studio et voilà le premier
garçon de quitter ce qu'est l'amour est
vrai que ça c'est une expérience que
j'ai pas eu en même temps j'ai beaucoup
de tendresse pour les gens qui aiment et
garçons se bat contre un qui serait pas
content qu'il y ait un truc fils est
mort
je suis incroyablement attirés par les
jeux ne pas avoir trouvé beau un mec
vraiment par exemple je ne trouvais pas
aujourd'hui des styles ferait un bon
jour n'a aucun tabou moral par rapport à
cela la première chanson que c'est vrai
que c'est pour bourvil et que c'était la
girafe ouais c'est ça la petite passe
accuser clairement et la mare ce que
pour vous physiquement mais c'était un
type extraordinaire moi j'étais je
voulais pas écrire avec bourvil était le
directeur artistique de ce lait les
pâtes et les petits s'occupait de crise
noté jacques savoie fonctionne bien qui
était très c'était l'époque booster les
jeunes qu'il est la loi ils avaient
envie lui de faire travailler des gens
ne loue que pourvu ouais hein
et donc il y était formidablement
floyd sur un patois oui c'est bien ça
pour vous parce que vous avez chanté moi
c'était pas du tout mon truc j'ai ce qui
m'intéresse c'est les beatles et et mais
moi écrivez-moi sert contraire ne doit
sa présence aujourd'hui il a absolument
pas gentil comme un truc revenus
d'ensemble bon bein moi mais ça m'a
permis d'étudier au partage
est ce que t'as pas eu un complexe quoi
vis-à-vis du rock and roll je dis
toujours je fais pas du rock and roll
c'est la routine yousif l'air de dire
bon c'est pas complètement du rock and
roll est ce que t'as pas aisée est ce
que finalement tu es passé du côté bonne
élève et tu serais pas assez distroll
pour être vraiment revenir que c'est à
l'intérieur et je pense que c'est
ministre de l'intérieur handicap par
rapport à ça c'est parler certes à
l'heure ouais c'est brillant très sage
continuellement et ouais ouais c'est
leur bon gars et signe un billet dans
notre seule vraie et 6 contres et un
intérieur sais pas si c'est lié à sa
première production c'est vrai que
c'était dur évident cette disette en
allemand les règles en cas de la ram a
permis à guy crevier on parle d'un
montant rien c'est un petit peu celui
des deux bords ision qui a fait 1
l'animé et nous on s'est dit on n'arrête
pas de nous dire où et l'américain
peabody intéressant l'europe c'est fait
pour les américains j'ai dit bon affirme
admise à la veille chez la dentelle
chantilly la personne ne savait que je
comprends et donc les programmateurs de
radio on y voit là c'est vraiment de la
ligue américaine et fait maintenant
c'est un pédalier avec nous tout ça oui
on a été pêché acquis pour chanter en
anglais
il fait il y en a vendu un livre et mixé
par lui dire j'ai apprécié a tout perdu
en juin 33 tours chapelet puzzle voilà
c'était quoi ce foulard j'avais gagné je
les unir deux jours gallen face à
phoenix
je voulais faire un concerto avec un
groupe avec une guitare électrique une
basse et une batterie alors qu'ils
travaillaient et la jolie 300c des
colonies plus celle que je devais faire
par la suite on était dedans mais c'est
un homme qui est extraordinaire je
l'écouté des postes clés c'est une
double son premier drame dans ta vie
c'est et quand le vrai drame contre
hitler a perdu mon frère n'est certes
pas très chic était
[Musique]
c'est lui qui m'a appris beaucoup
beaucoup de choses vraies
un ami s'appelant toile s'est suicidé
aussi oui c'est vrai ça c'est premier
drame
c'est un ami d'enfance avec lequel j'ai
fait six tués mais maintenant ce qui est
suicidé 2 pourquoi je crois que son
histoire d'amour
justement y arrive t'on premier amour
grande à moi mais moi j'ai eu très peu
d'amour elle s'est dernièrement
oui je crois que c'est à peu près le
premier important et après je les
remplis pourquoi c'est qu'il faut le
demander
on lui a demandé ses pour comparer car
c'est comme tomber malaise de munitions
fini le récoltant son deuxième grand
amour et la critique je crois c est fier
et qui fait maintenant
son couloir lancée affamée de fidèles
oui assez
julien clerc nous a raconté qu'elles lui
ont pas fait l été avec lui il est un
peu dans l'ombre et que toi au contraire
sur des mises dans la lumière crois que
c'est ça enfin d'or de l'amour entre
vous parce que c'est ça qui vous a réuni
est lié pour longtemps je sais pas tu
sais je crois que c'est très difficile
de dire pourquoi saint sava ina un
couple qui après ça va plus je crois que
c'est très très difficile en tout cas de
passer sa vie avec la même personne ça
en a l'air de demander la savane à sa
miraculeux a déjà concédé un certain âge
et ton premier succès personnel
quant à chanter des chants seront les
premiers trucs a vraiment marché de toit
par toi là où ils viennent il a gobé du
pianiste
ça a été tout d'un coup ça a été
incroyable parce que tout d'un coup des
villages là c'était page et john john
d'emplois non
c'était c'était déjà un peu
4e sacré album frein à oui il fait plein
de gens qui commençaient à penser que
planteur c'était là on y est plutôt et
chansons pour les autres grands exemples
quand les développements nous et quand
j'arrête je fais des chansons plus aux
autres moi j'arrive à bord n'ont à aucun
moment
non mais vous comptez 3 leucate et oui
pas un peu vrai donc pas mes cheveux
blancs dont souvient ce temps qu'elle et
moi je sais un bond de 10 mois voire
vous avez marqué mais après tu dois
avoir des comme ça le texte l'incident
1980 oui dans un article une interview
jean marc benamou dans le quotidien le
parisien avoue avoir tout premiers
cheveux blancs et j'en ai tout un plat
ouais vous savez absolument parce
qu'elle est arrivée
[Musique]